well I'm here i anti-law I don't like
regulation and I like to shame people
into behaving better
hi I'm Ted baliker with Reason TV and
today I'll be speaking with Amy Alcott
Alcon is a nationally syndicated advice
columnist she blogs daily at advice God
is calm and his author of the new book
icy rude people one woman's battle to
beat some manners into in polite society
your book is very funny very clever tell
me why did you write it well I just saw
all of a sudden about 10 years ago that
we were living in mainland you know
people just taking an advantage of other
people right and left and so you're in a
coffee shop someone's streaming they're
loud dull cell conversation into your
praying and my feeling is as a
libertarian your right to stream your
loud dull cell conversation into my ears
ends where my ears begin so shared space
all that you know I started to sort of
just don't be an activist against
rudeness you mentioned that your
libertarian I think a lot of people
would say when confronted with rudeness
there ought to be a lot of people are
yapping too much at Starbucks there
should be a lot that you know bans
yapping at Starbucks
well I'm very anti law I don't like
regulation and I like to shame people
into behaving better and I think that's
a better deterrent than lost people
break laws all the time but shame is I
think I'm much much better deterrent
because you're thinking oh wait she put
that girl's phone number and loves cell
conversation on the Internet
you know gee I don't want that to happen
to me where the law and they're not
gonna catch me and so talk about a one
of your you do this a lot you make a
habit yes standing up against rudeness
how do you shame people well you know
like I was saying I'm send me just cafes
was shouting into her cell phone about
her eyeglasses at 8 o'clock in the
morning you know I just look around and
all these people they're just so
disturbed by it and I started to try to
you know give a send a message like look
we're all hearing you and this is
obnoxious so I stand up and I start
taking notes very visibly I'm a big
person red hair this woman is so
oblivious to anything but her own needs
that she just doesn't see me and so I
knew she'd do it she puts out her phone
number
so I thought hey obviously if you're
shouting your personal information at 8
o'clock in the morning you're lonely and
you want people to know it so I put a
phone number and all their information
on the Internet Anna Sturgis needs new
glasses and people called her from
around the world Anna your glasses are
ready see she's probably not yapping too
much at Starbucks right
and then and so other people who see
this they aren't necessarily going to be
nicer people but if they're also these
loud rude stirs they'll think hmm that
could happen to me maybe I'll be
considerate one of the interesting
things about your book is that you you
show these non these these these ways
that don't have anything to do with
passing laws that basically shame people
a lot of it has to do with using new
technology can you tell the story of the
woman in the New York City Subway who
sort of took the law into her own hands
by snapping yeah I'd love this there is
a great headline I think in the New York
Daily News own and the vegetarian about
this guy he had exposed himself to this
woman and apparently a bunch of other
women on the New York City subway you
know so she pulled her camera phone out
of her purse snapped a photo and showed
a policewoman in the subway who did
nothing about it people have this idea
that the police are going to save you
and solve your problems unless there's a
body on your kitchen floor that's
probably not gonna happen you have to do
it yourself
so she posted it on Flickr and I guess
like a day later 12 hours later they
knew who the guy was they had his
picture in the front page of The Daily
News and I love that I love it that's
gonna be more of a deterrent than some
you know peeper or pervert law in New
York obviously it was not a deterrent to
this guy you mentioned Starbucks things
like that what are the other rudeness
hotspots Oh people who are rude drivers
and you know will just you know do
horrible horrible things to you on the
road what else oh telemarketing I hate
hate hate telemarketing it's a form of
theft I call it the business of abuse
you have no right to take a following
hijack a phone line I pay for and steal
my time to make your marketing cost
cheaper so if you do this to me
I will charge you I'm not mean to the
person who calls me on the phone I find
the honcho of the company they're
selling for find his home number
zabba search comm and I call him at home
preferably at dinnertime chew him out
for calling me at home and then I
invoice him for use of my time in my
phone line and get them to pay me how's
that work okay I've gotten hundreds of
dollars and actually I got the idea from
a posting and hit and-run Tyler Cowen
the economist had said you should charge
people you know for doing this to you
and so I posted on my blog prices I
think it's three thousand seven hundred
and seventy three dollars and twenty
seven cents or something for bothering
me during my dinner and the fact that
you don't look that up it's like
ordering grilled cheese were there no
prices it's $45 you ate it sorry you
didn't ask just because other people
don't request that you pay or demand in
my case hey you're gonna have to pay me
and you demanded and received $1
restitution from a woman who was
stealing your your attention I believe
that's how you free right right I was at
this no cellphones cafe I go to and that
sign there which is all over the place
you know at the door on the counter did
not stop her from shouting into her
phone at 8 o'clock in the morning 6
inches from my head this is an empty
place just her at the table behind me
I'm at this booth and so I told her
there's no cell phone policy and she
gonna return it something about my karma
I was gonna bad karma
yeah whatever lady this neo hippy by way
of Neiman Marcus so she goes out comes
back in and I said you know you stole my
attention you know my time is valuable
she said I'll give you a dollar so I
said oh cool I was not mad anymore
because if you're gonna pay me you're
not abusing me you're hiring me and at
that rate
I get 120 dollars an hour for listening
to loud dull conversations I'm totally
cool with it what do you say to people
who say well you know just loosen up a
little bit more so what if someone's
chatting at at Starbucks you go there
you know it's gonna be a social
environment
okay well conversations between people
that's fine I like to be out amongst
people I really I'm a chatty girl but
actually it turns out that when there's
a one-sided phone conversation it forces
your brain to pay attention in a way you
wouldn't if people having to kite
two-sided conversations your brain
apparently tries to fill in the other
side of the conversation so it's
annoying to you in a way two sided
conversations aren't so what I do is use
the internet and modern technology to
bring back the constraints for the small
towns small tribe where you would have
been shamed and you know kicked off the
island
essentially for being a jerk and there
were a lot of websites that have popped
up to fight rudeness to correct oh yeah
there's one kill the calls calm against
telemarketing I love that one the guy
he's just he's a bleeding-heart
Republican always on some cause and you
know he just got these 30 calls a day
for mortgage people he said look take me
off your list he's a busy guy he didn't
want to track them down but when they
wouldn't excuse me they and he ended up
suing them and he got I think $5,000 and
he tells you how to do it I just love
that site
holler back NYC
oh yeah that's where that's where the
girl I think posted her that's really do
postings more of you know more postings
of perverts you know who expose
themselves so you know pervert Emporium
yeah right
and so I think it's interesting that you
you draw a lot on evolutionary biology I
mean the book is very fun and
interesting but it's also grounded in
these these ideas another one is the
tragedy of the Commons which will be
very familiar concept to econ geeks how
does that play into the foundation of
your book I actually like to call it the
tragedy of the on the Commons and that
is like the Starbucks example you gave
where people take over a shared space as
if it's their own and so what I bring
out in the book is that they're stealing
from us now if somebody takes your
wallet it's a tangible thing it's there
and it's gone but what these people are
taking from us is our time our peace of
mind in the case of loud neighbors our
good night's sleep and so what I say is
that we need to see these things as
resources so we can refuse to be
victimized by these people when people
think of rudeness smoking comes up a lot
and you can I think a lot of
libertarians hate smoking but they also
hate laws against smoking how does
someone like you approach that is he
smoking like farting you're putting up
this herb noxious fume and it seems sort
of impolite to do that you know it's the
old you know your right to punch me in
the nose and swear my nose begins and my
lungs are not your lungs and so I think
that people should be considerate but I
also think if you want to open up a
smoking bar hey you know I don't have to
go there but that you know if you're in
an elevator with me you know don't be
lighting up cuz maybe I don't like smoke
do you think your non-law approach would
have figured out a better way to deal
with smoking
well squirt guns but I guess it's no
criterion my friends new people come
over I don't want people smoke in my
house they go out my porch I mean that's
just sort of how you behave as a polite
person and I think that some of these
sort of like activist bits that I do
they sort of encourage the kind of
behavior where it's like let's all
behave well let's be adults so we don't
need a you know a government you know
that comes down on us I just I prefer to
not have legislation prefer to encourage
better behavior and what would you
advise our viewers if if and when
they're confronted with rudeness which
well I'm what's called a costly Punisher
you know it's I think that's from
economics it's it's it means that I will
it cost to myself and at no benefit sort
of enforce things when I feel there's an
injustice done so if you're a person
like me and you can speak up big mouth
and all that tell people do something
you know post their picture on the
Internet if they're doing something
flagrantly rude but if you're not
actually I say to recognize that
basically I figured out that we're rude
based on robbed and Dunbar's research
because we live in societies too big for
our brains and so we're around strangers
all the time you treat strangers
differently than friends and so I
encourage people to treat strangers like
neighbors and then maybe life won't feel
so much like one big wrestling smackdown